[موسيقى]
وكانها لوحه فنيه تظهر اندماج الالوان
والتضاريس في ما بينها وامتدادها
لكلوميترات
انها مدرجات وحقول الاروس التي تتربع على
اعالي الجبال
[موسيقى]
دراجات حقول الارز
مئه عام يتم غرس الارز في هذه الحقول
المليئه بالمياه عمليه حصاد الارز بدات في
اكتوبر تشرين الاول وستمر لشهر ونصف في كل
خطوه تصل المياه
يقومون بهذه العمليه ست ساعات اليوميه
67 عاما مقابل 20 يورو يوميا
حصدوا الارز عمل جسدي شاق جدا
لانهم استطاعوا مع مرور الزمن استغلال هذه
الاراضي لصالحهم على الرغم من صعوبه
المهمه
الطبيعيه
حقول الارز
هي نفسها التي استعملها اجدادهم
ايوه يا استاذ محمود
مثل العام الماضي نقوم بملا 60 كغم من
الارز كل عشرين دقيقه 150000
على اسقف المنازل في تعريضه لاشعه الشمس
في هذه المنطقه الجبليه الاستوائيه
ستقابل في الاسواق نساء يرتدين لباسهن
التقليدي
اغلبيه سكان الضاحيه يعيشون من وراء زراعه
الارض
الارز الابيض
امر عادي ان يقدم لك طبق عروس في الاسواق
مع بدايه موسم الحصاد هنا
اتناوله منذ طفولته انه لذيذ جدا
طريقه تقليديه اخرى
والسمك
[تصفيق]
التي تقوم بالتخصيب الطبيعي
والاسماك نفسها في اطباق الصيني
انها حلقه مهمه لضمان استمرار هذه
التضاريس الخلابه التي وجدت لها مكانا في
التراث العالمي لليونسكو